foreign you for joining us welcome
brothers and sisters esteemed guests as
we
continue on through our journey
through the book provisions for the
hereafter
authored by the late and esteemed
scholar of islam
now in this installment
we would to discuss
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would recite what the general
pattern for his recitation and prayer
was now we discussed before what he
would recite
we discussed before how the recitation
itself would be
right and elongating certain vowels etc
now we're going to discuss how he would
disperse that recitation
throughout his prayer following that we
will discuss
the bowing position rising from
and we will also speak about
some of the things that he would say in
court aside from what is
generally known insha'allah
[Silence]
one of the things we're going to
understand here
is that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would not ever stick to one
specific particular
chapter of the quran or section of the
quran
for every salah meaning he would
traditionally only recite these chapters
during this salah
except for salah and
these two prayers he would
recite what we have mentioned before
and he would stick to that every other
prayer he would generally recite certain
things or
or chapters of certain lengths but not
necessarily
always right he says
he says and one of his
ways his traditions
is that generally he would always recite
the
the entire chapter to its comp with its
to its completion so if he would start a
chapter he would end it he would finish
the whole chapter
and sometimes he would disperse that
chapter
between two units of prayer between two
rakah so let's say for example
right so he's reciting
you've got three rakah the first he will
recite let's say half of
surat al-araf and then the second he
will
recite the other half of surat al-araf
so usually if he starts a chapter he
will finish it in one draka
if not he may distribute it
over two away
and as for reciting just the ends
of chapters right the end of a chapter
of the quran
often times people recite the ends of
the chapters
meaning the last 10 or 15 verses of the
chapters especially the very long
chapters
of the quran usually allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
sums up the general principles and the
generalities
of what has passed
in the chapter so you'll find a lot of
chapters of the quran where they end it
they end with a lot of principles and
morals to derive from the stories that
passed in that chapter etc so a lot of
people to
recite those endings
as well people to choose pick and
choose different places throughout the
quran now
this is permissible but it's not
necessarily the sunnah
right and we discussed many times before
the difference between permissible and
the sunnah
and that means that everything that is
the sunnah is permissible but not
everything that is permissible is
necessarily
the sunnah
he says
and as for reciting two chapters in a
single recap
this is something that he used to do
customarily
in the optional prayers prayers at
night
right
and as for reciting with redundancy the
same
chapter in the first same chapter in the
second
this is something that would rarely ever
happen we mentioned an example of that
with surah in salah
before we proceed there are a couple of
questions that come up
what about if a person recited only
surat al-fatiha
we would say this is valid
the person has left off something that
is very virtuous
and could be argued is the essence of
the prayer
but it is a valid prayer technically
because the only thing that is a pillar
of salah
what about if a person recited surat
al-fatiha more than once
so let's say you recite surat al-fatiha
and then you recite it again
in the same raqqah is that permissible
yes that falls into the generality of
recite what is easy for you of the quran
a person could do that it's never been
narrated that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam ever did that
but all of the quran is
permissible to recite during the
standing position
of salah another question
is is bismillah
a verse of surat al-fatiha meaning when
i'm reciting
when i am reciting do i have to recite
along with it bismillah
the correct answer is that bismillah
is an independent verse
which marks the beginning of chapters
it is an independent verse which marks
the beginning of chapters
it is not a verse of surat al-fatiha
in the correct opinion though many of
the scholars of islam do conti
do consider it to be as such
and so it is better and more correct
that a person recite bismillah
even if only to him or herself
these are some of the issues that arise
with regards to
recitation in prayer
he says
he says and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
used to extend the first over the second
and we mentioned this as a general rule
salah should be something that starts
out long
and progresses to shorter right so the
first raka
is the longest and the last
of any given prayer is should be the
shortest
right and rukur and the bowing and
prostration
positions they should as well
complement the standing position so a
person is not going to stand for a very
long time
and then maybe make very brief little
cooler and then make extremely long so
you this is not correct
this throws off the balance of the
prayer the prayer should start
long-winded and it should
progress to shorter from longer to
shorter
right and so the first raka
would be longer than the second and the
second longer than the third
and the third longer than the fourth etc
etc
right and sometimes
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would make the first soraka so long
that no one is coming and arriving to
salah anymore
meaning that you know as you start
prayer
people are kind of trickling in
right but if that prayer lasts
long enough meaning that first soraka
lasts long enough
everybody who is going to come for
prayer will have already come
and this is something that would happen
in the time of the prophet salallahu
that the first raqqa would be so long
that
everyone who is coming to prayer has
already come nobody will have missed the
first s
he says and when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would conclude his
recitation
for any given he would raise his hands
[Arabic recitation]
and making now
let's look at the exact wording that is
here he says
he says when he would finish his
prayer he would raise his hands
and make techbeer while going into the
court
while transitioning from standing into
the
bowing position what does that mean
this tekbeer the techbear of you know
[Arabic recitation]
transitioning between standing and
rukur
between standing and sujood between the
sajdah between sujud and standing etc
every time we move
[Arabic recitation]
is referred to by the scholars of islam
as
takbirot al-intercal
this is referred to by the focahe as
techbiora tul intercal
that is the the tech beer of transition
the tech beer of transition and it's an
important name
why is that important because the name
defines it
and it defines its proper place this is
a mistake that is made a lot
by people who pray and that is
that when i conclude my recitation
and i wish to move into the court the
beginning of my tequila
should start with the beginning of my
motion and transition into bowing
and it should end when i reach to the
position of bowing
it shouldn't be before i start to bow
and it shouldn't be
after i finish bowing right
[Arabic recitation]
right as i move
as i move the takbir is being made
and it should start with the start of my
movement
and should end when i reach that
position
it is takbiro tul intercal it is the
takbir which takes place in transition
from one position to the next this is
its definition this is its name
give it this name to identify its proper
placement
[Arabic recitation]
and then they start to make rokura
this is incorrect and this has placed
the takbir
in the standing position where it does
not belong
likewise and this happens a lot with
people who lead salah
right they will say and they will move
when they reach allah so they'll
this happens a lot in sujud with people
who lead saleh
this happens in the first sujud and this
happens in
standing after sujud
so they don't want anybody to reach the
ground and subdued before them as the
imam
so what do they do they don't make
takabhi until they reach the sujood
position
[Arabic recitation]
this is an invalid takbir
you have placed it in sujud its
placement is in transition
likewise people don't want anybody to
get up before them so
they will get up completely reach the
standing position and then they will say
[Arabic recitation]
you have placed this tech beer in the
standing position before
recitation and that is an improper
placement of it
that invalidates it because
it is to be made in transition not in
position now
there's a difference between making a
portion of it
in transition and making the entire
thing
after transition what does that mean
well so for example a person is standing
from sujud or going
into the court let's say they begin
and they start and as they are in
their as they are
in transition from standing to the core
they begin the tech beer
but they complete the tech beer while
they are in the position of
or while they are in the position of
sujud or while they are in the standing
position this is permissible
this is fine as the scholars of islam
mention
however to completely take it out of
transition and put it into one
position or the other this invalidates
this tech being
and so the motion
from the these things should happen
simultaneously raising the hands
making tech beer and going to suju
these things should have these things
should happen
simultaneously in the transition
right he says
now he gives us the exact
position that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would be making
he says when he would arrive at rukur he
would place his two hands
on his knees he would spread his fingers
and he would almost grasp at his knees
almost as if he is holding his knees in
his hand
of course the the the legs are straight
right the legs are straight so a person
can't necessarily grasp their legs
but they are grabbing at their knees
as if their knees are in their hands
right
and he would bend his elbows
while he is in the core his elbows would
be bent they would not be
straight sometimes people to make
roku this
this is not how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make
he would make with the arms slightly
bent
this right
he says
not only would he bend his arms
his elbows he would break his elbows but
as well
he would fan them out away from his
sides
he would not make it this he would
fan his elbows out
away from his sides
he would extend his back he would
stretch his back
out and make his back as flat as
possible
so his record his back would not be bent
his back would be as flat as possible
and he is
would also hold his head in a natural
position
which would be which would be
relative to the straightness of his back
so his back
would be in line with his head his head
would neither be lifted way up
nor would it be dangling down his head
would just be
straight with his back so his spine
would be
straight
[Silence]
he says and when he would be in rukur
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would say
subhana rabbi this is what he would say
and sometimes he would say along with
that
subhana bina
so what would he say subhan subhan
will be this
was something that was added near the
end of his life
different variations of this
and in sujud that this was something
that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam adopted and started to say
after the revelation
foreign
so this chapter of the quran was
revealed regarding the
conquest of mecca right the conquest of
mecca which took place in the seventh or
eighth year after hijrah difference of
opinion amongst the historians of islam
the point is is that this is something
that he adopted later on
prior to this he was known in the
narration of
even mr ud and others he was known to
have said in his
a person can say this as many times as
he would like
there is a narration in jamaica that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would say this ten times
the narration has weakness in it
what is most customary amongst the
scholars of phil to mention is three
times
however one time will suffice
however that one time is not
in this way that mangles the words and
compresses them this is not valid
according to all of the scholars of
islam
rather it is
right and what is best is at least
three times and some scholars of islam
mention that this is the bare minimum
right this is how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
this is the particular remembrance or
statement he would customarily make in
rukur there are other things that we'll
mention later inshallah
as for the addition of subhan arabiya
this is a weak narration
literally translates to
i proclaim the profession
of my lord i proclaim
that allah is
disassociated from any imperfection
that is my greatest and great lord
roughly this is what it means
and his you the usual length of his
bowing would be about the length of ten
tesbihat so subhan arab be allahim ten
times
as we just mentioned right and this is
this is actually something that we
should address and that is a problem
that people have when they do something
a lot
the body tends to want to take shortcuts
right so we want to summarize
so a person begins praying when they
first learn how to pray
and doing everything perfectly and then
after that
years go by and it turns into
whatever it is that people say you hear
are people saying all kinds of things
and this now turns into something which
is totally incoherent
and is not valid it has to be said just
that
this happens a lot with all kinds of
things such as
alhamdulillah a lot of times people will
say it the
alhamdulillah this is not correct
this completely changes the meaning but
second of all
it's very it's a very
it's a very passive way of saying
something that is very great
in the eyes of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
likewise
upon the prophet sallallahu alaihi you
hear lecturers a lot or
people that give khutbah or what have
you orators
as they call them speaking
and often times when they go to say the
prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam which is a
dua
right we would hear sallallahu sallam
or whatever it is people say right and
this also happens
in in writing in writing
the books the scholars of hadith
have books written on the etiquettes
of hadith
writing hadith reading hadith memorizing
hadith speaking hadith etc
all of these things and one of the
things that they mention is
what is known with the scholars of
hadith as salaam
salaam is an abbreviation
right of sallallahu alaihi wasallam so
they write
saud to represent sallah and then
lam to represent allah an ayan to
represent
alaihi and meme to represent
was sallam right and so
they will abbreviate it right
this is not permissible in islam
it is not permissible and this is
something that specifically
the scholars of hadith and the scholars
of islam have
have looked down upon
and prohibited in their writings that a
person abbreviate that we have the same
thing
in english people will say instead of
sallallahu
people write s a w you know
w or s a a w or all of these different
abbreviations
and this is something first of all
it is foreign to arabic language
right in the arabic language there are
no
shortcuts that look this there's
there are no abbreviations this
that's number one not in this form
number two
this is something which is articulates a
lack of respect for the
worship of making a salah upon the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
so every time a person says
upon that individual 10 times
and as an anecdote it's mentioned that
the first man to have written salaam
his hand actually became
crippled after he had written this this
is something that the scholars of hadith
mention
and so the point is is that it is not
befitting it is not becoming
of a muslim to mangle the words
of worship right to mangle the words of
you know and this happens a lot with
tasbih
after salah right we see people making
after in a superhuman speed it is
impossible to say subhanallah
that fast spa
right fingers moving so fast you can't
even count that fast
this is just a waste of time that's
that's all that is
there there is no reward in this right
to just spasm it should be subhan allah
subhan allah subhan allah subhan allah
subhanallah and we will speak about that
when we get to it inshaallah
after we conclude the description of
prayer the point here
is that this is worship right
we are not looking for quantity always
in worship we are looking for quality
right if you say subhana rabbi al-alim
one time
properly with presence of mine that is
better than ten times
improperly without presence of mine
he says that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's
bowing position would be ten
roughly the length of ten test behad
[Silence]
and sometimes occasionally he is
make his bowing position and his sujud
position
the same length as his standing position
the recitation of
yet this is something that the prophet
alaihi wasallam would only occasionally
do
in the night prayer when he's praying by
himself
right as well
we want to discuss the length of
urukur and sujud we'd also to
discuss what is
not permissible to say in quran sujud
and that is
it is not permissible in rukur and sujud
to recite the quran so if a person is in
a state of
they're in a state of sujud it is
impermissible for a person to recite
the quran as the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
has prohibited yet if there is some dua
in the quran
that are found in the quran if a person
were to
make this dua in a state of rukur or
sujud
with not with the intention of reciting
the quran then this is permissible
inshallah
he says fahed you
he says the
traditionally the way the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would customarily pray it would be in a
way that
the rest all of his salah is very
similar
right in that light progression from
longest
to shortest
and standing positions all kind of
complement each other in their length
and sometimes he would say in his
dua so meaning
this literally which translates to
my lord allah he is one who is
absolutely infallible he is absolutely
holy he is the lord
of the angels and the spirit meaning
jibril
or the spirit of faith
and in you i have believed
and to you i have submitted myself
my hearing and my vision
have both become
very still in your presence
and likewise my tendons and my
innards and my bones have all become
very still in your presence out of
exaltation
and something that usually he would only
make in
the night prayer
allah
[Silence]
he says he would
then raise from
saying in the process again this is a
this is
[Arabic recitation]
to take place in the transition
right transition from to standing
the person should be saying
they should not say it before they go
and they should not say it after they're
already standing
wrong it should be semi-allah
exactly in that way and he would raise
his hands with this
right this is something that i see a lot
of times
people make a mistake in it is a
misinterpretation of the sunnah
and i know that this is kind of
going to be a bit i don't know i
wouldn't say controversial
but i would say this is going to be a
bit
a statement that is often misunderstood
and that is that
not every piece of knowledge
is appropriate for every individual
right which is one of the reasons why
the extreme influx of translation
of classical arabic works and even the
printing press in arabic
has not done the most good
for the muslim ummah there was a time
when the scholars of islam
were privy to things that they could
understand
where the rest of the people may very
well misunderstand
and this is a principle of disseminating
knowledge
right there is a narration in sahih
al-bukhari in the book of knowledge
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
was writing with muay the bin jebel
right while they've been jebel was
writing behind him we spoke about muay
thai
that he is one of the scholars of islam
one of the greatest scholars of islam
with regards to
jurispudence and that's the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
asked in this narration
do you know what the rights of allah
over the slaves are and what the slaves
what the rights of the slaves upon allah
are
and why i have responded
allah and his messenger know best
meaning teach me inform me tell me
he said
he said the right of allah over the
servants is that they worship him
alone and not associate anyone
unto he in their worship of him he said
allah
and the rights that allah has placed
upon himself
and for on behalf of the servants
meaning the rights of the servants upon
allah
are that he not torture or punish those
who do not associate any partners until
he
then said ya rasulullah
shall
he said then said oh messenger of allah
should i not
give this great news to the people
should i not announce it to everyone
he said do not announce it to the
general masses
because they will become complacent
they will become complacent what does
that mean
that one of the aspects of the meanings
of this narration is that
not all knowledge is appropriate for all
people
right the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam selectively told this to muat
because muad would understand this and
he would
excel this would make him more excellent
whereas this kind of knowledge may very
well be misinterpreted
by others who are less knowledgeable
hence
affecting in a negative fashion their
worship of allah subhanahu wa
this is something that comes with years
of experience of teaching people
that a person does not tell people
things that will be easily misunderstood
and cause them to become complacent or
lazy
cause them to become
undis undisciplined right
and so example
for example when it comes to
the books of hadith the books of
narration
let's say the the six books of hadith
is these books have not only been
printed
and distributed to everyone but they
have also been
translated and distributed
and this very well may act to compound
problems because
now everybody thinks that he understands
and it takes years of experience to
understand these books
these books are for people who
understand
how to put things in their proper place
and so
people will start to just swim in all
these narrations
and derive rulings for themselves and
the
biggest enemy of knowledge is not
ignorance
it is the illusion of knowledge this is
the greatest
enemy to knowledge the greatest enemy to
knowledge is not that you don't know
the greatest enemy to knowledge is to
think that you know when you don't
right and so this
opening the floodgates of all
information to
everyone which we have in our time not
just in islamic
literature and knowledge but in
all facets of knowledge this has flooded
our minds with information that we have
not been taught
and have not been given time to properly
process and so we are people who are
full of facts
and we have very little knowledge right
and we discussed this before
and so back to
misinterpreting the sunnah
i've seen a lot of people make mistakes
in all of these parts that we have
spoken about
because they have misinterpreted
especially
in english or in another language other
than arabic misinterpreted
the books of hadith right
now here is the issue
when you have arabic
and you are reading the arabic there is
one element of mistake that takes place
there
roughly i mean there could be misprints
and so forth but
the main the main
part that may cause the the the
weakest link there is your understanding
of the arabic language and you're
understanding more specifically
of the language and terminology of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
but when you translate that into another
language
now this has been compounded right
now you're relying on your understanding
which relies upon the understanding of
a translator and there are a lot of
mistranslations
unfortunately especially of late
translation has become a fad
it's become a money thing and so
everyone who speaks a little bit of
arabic
dabbles a little bit now starts to
translate all kinds of things
all kinds of incorrect ways right there
is no such thing as
translating the exact words you're not
translating the exact words you're
translating the meanings that you have
understood from those words the
translation
is a very very precise science people go
to school for it
and it takes a lot of understanding for
a person to properly and adequately
translate
right the scholars of islam mention
four conditions for translation
and most of the time
three or sometimes even all four are
not met
what was that and so back to the
point here which we will end with and
that is that the mistake that is often
made
is that when we read the narration of
ibn abbas
that the prophet salallahu
well people understand that to be sad
this says misplaced where this is
intended this is not what
ibn abbas was referring to this is now
before
sujud now i'm raising my hands before
sujud i'm not raising my hands after
what his meant is he would raise samia
[Arabic recitation]
right this is the time when a person is
to raise his hands from raising from
rukur to the standing position
that's the raising of the hands and the
motion and transition from bowing to
standing
should all be simultaneous at the same
time
we will end with that today inshaallah
tonight
[Arabic recitation]